oh hi everybody my name is Kim crease I
work in the consumer and community
research section at the Federal Reserve
Board of Governors you heard my
colleague BJ Blum talk earlier this
morning I work in the same division as
him I'm gonna talk a little bit more
about kind of apply it get a science
using are in a government setting so my
section does an annual survey every year
and I'm going to talk today about some
work we've done to use our to automate
some of our production processes for
that survey so just a brief kind of
overview of the talk I'll give a little
bit of background on the survey context
more on the survey data and what we make
the data look like then I'm going to
spend the rest of the time just talking
about how our fits into that how it
works and then showing some code OOP so
standard disclaimer the views expressed
here are mine alone and they don't
reflect the position of the Board of
Governors or any of its staff so some
background so my section runs a large
annual survey called the survey of
household economics and decision making
more commonly known as shed so we do
this survey annually and we're a pretty
large survey so we're a nationally
representative survey and we focus on
the financial lives and experiences of
us individuals and households so one
emphasize again I'm in a consumer and
community research group at the Fed so I
think a lot of people think banks
monetary policy so we're really kind of
like a people focus group at the Fed
source server is really cool we ask
people a lot of different questions on a
really on a pretty big range of topics
so some kind of things we cover economic
well-being so how are you faring
financially financial fragility if you
had some type of emergency expense how
would that affect your finances how a
thot affect your well-being and then
lots of other stuff that were really
interested in in people's lives so
student loans education how you finance
education how you feel about financing
your
education income employment your
experience with accessing credit the
bank the making system and then just a
bunch of stuff about housing and
retirement and also some financial
literacy stuff so you may have even
heard of us we got a lot of press
coverage in particular for our economic
well-being measures we're really unique
survey in that we provide a lot of
subjective measures of economic
well-being and we also get a lot of
coverage for the financial fragility
piece I mentioned so if you had
emergency expenses how you would cover
them so I want to just kind of give a
snapshot of the data and highlight some
of the nuances of our our data and our
use case so the public use data data set
which I'll be using today has eleven
thousand three hundred and sixteen
observations and just under four hundred
variables so each observation in our
dataset is a respondent so that
corresponds to one person so the kind of
data we get in this data set we get a
bunch of metadata on the respondent so
how long you took to take our survey how
long you spend on certain questions etc
we got a bunch of demographic
information on ours on the respondents
in income education race geography
things like that and then of course we
have our survey questions and we asked a
lot of questions and they come in a lot
of different formats but kind of the two
main formats we have here as we ask
exclusive multiple-choice questions so
think like yes or no questions we give
you we ask you a question we give you a
list of things we only let you choose
one of those things and then we have
another type of question that's pretty
common is this select all that apply
or like grid multiple-choice questions
so we ask you a question we give you a
list of things and we tell you that you
can select a bunch of options from that
or you can tell us yes or no on those
options okay and just to give kind of a
sense of what the data look like so here
we have the case ID that's a unique
identifier for each person and then some
of the metadata and a bunch of the the
rest of the data we have okay and then
now I'm going to talk I'm just a little
bit more about survey what we asked how
it shows up in the data because we have
a lot of different types of questions
and then what
we want to take that data and make it
look like and that's that's really where
art comes in so this is the question
that was referenced in the Reuters
article that I showed
so overall which one of the following
best describes how well you're managing
financially these days and this is one
of those questions that we only let you
pick one option here right so you you
can't tell us that you're both living
comfortably and finally is finding it
difficult a good buy that would really
confuse us so this is what that variable
is going to show up in the data like so
again we have our case ID and then just
one column for for that response and
that's pretty standard what you might
expect so we have this other question
and a lot of questions look like this we
ask people suppose you have an emergency
expense that costs $100 based on your
current financial situation how would
you pay for this expense and this is one
of those select all that apply questions
so we're really interested in how people
are going to pay for this if you're
gonna pay for this in a couple different
ways maybe you'll pay some of it in cash
maybe you'll borrow some of it from a
friend or family member really want to
know that that's gonna look a little bit
different in the data so as we saw here
we have a through I so each of these
gets its own column for yes or no
whether or not you selected that box and
if you didn't select anything it'll come
up as n/a and we'll get a yes in the
refuse column I'll grab the end okay so
I showed you kind of what the data look
like and this is really the kind of
finished product that we we take that
data and make it into this nice pretty
annual report so we do this every year
in 2018 which was published this past
May our main report had 10 chapters so
it was 64 pages 31 tables 36 charts
which will be relevant later and then
our appendix which was broken into two
separate parts so the first part is just
our survey instrument so the questions
we ask who they get field the two etc
and then the second part is tabbing out
each of those questions so we want to
see what the questions look like among
our whole whole sample and just to kind
of give a little more about what that
actually looks like in the report so we
get this text this analysis and all
throughout the report are scattered just
a bunch of different types of tables and
charts so at the Fed we're really
interested in looking at a lot of
different things so we look at how
people within groups and we compare
across groups so we have some different
types of charts to kind of do that yeah
so kind of a nice classic is the bar
chart showing just family income
distribution this is just a crosstab so
we want to see what where you're getting
your income from and how that varies by
different age categories and then again
you can see down here wool will kind of
note where respondents might not might
be in different categories here and then
this is one where we're comparing
different groups so we take people who
tell us they have a stable income or
they have a varying income and then we
just want to look at how willing they
are to take financial risks so different
different types of charts and visuals
here okay so now I'm going to talk about
how well what our production process for
this report looks like and how our fits
into that so just kind of a pretty
high-level explanation for our
production process so one of our big our
first step really is we want to generate
all the numbers that are going to go
into the report so we're talking about
all the numbers that are in the text
that I showed you all the numbers and
the tables and charts and once we we
kind of have that settled our next step
is to generate the tables and charts and
all the visuals for the report and then
our final step in this process is a
quality control so we really want to
make sure that all our numbers are right
that we're doing everything correctly
before it goes up the door so today I'm
just gonna talk about all these steps
are very very data-intensive and take a
lot of work but I'm just going to talk
about the second step which is
generating tables and charts for the
report so it takes a lot of work to turn
the raw data
into analysis for the report especially
the generation of tables and charts like
I showed you before we have data that's
not always standard across different
questions and various variable types and
we have a lot of data and a lot of
questions so it can be a little bit
challenging so talk about some kind of
constraints we have here it's like I
said a lot of different tables and
charts we really want to be flexible
when we're setting up our analysis and
really want to be flexible in case we
decide we want to do something else last
minute maybe we want to change something
it should be it should be easy to do
that
and finally we well we do all the data
work and the analysis for this report we
don't actually go through the process of
making the book and publishing it we
have a publishing department that does
that and from us they need Excel
workbooks of underlying data for each
table and chart and they also need our
rendering of each table and chart so
they're gonna make it into that nice
format that I showed you in the report
but they need to know what it's going to
look like and and they need to know
beyond just an Excel workbook of that ok
so we use our for a lot of things our
previous process had a lot of manual
data entry such as copy and pasting so
is anyone familiar with a software
called Stata any economists in the room
ok right so prior to using our we use
data which is a great tool for using
economic data doing economic analysis
but it's not as flexible as our it's
what we used to do is do some
tabulations have a go into a log file
and then we would transfer that output
into an Excel workbook and you can write
directly from Stata to excel but we
still needed to do some reshaping of our
data but we just couldn't do or Stata
couldn't do for us so we needed to kind
of eliminate that process or eliminate
any any manual kind of entry of data or
copy and pasting so use our to do that
and we also use our to generate tables
in church for the
so at all editing needs from us is just
what the charts are going to look like
we can give that to them in just a PDF
so we can use our to do that and finally
this year we implemented get for version
control which was incredibly helpful for
us we had a lot of chapter files my
initials my co-workers initials v1 v2
this really eliminated that and just
made things much better okay so if I
don't have to if I have to convince you
our process with our is efficient no one
is spending time doing manual data entry
our process is flexible if we decide
last minute that we want to change some
type of graphic in our report before it
goes out we don't have to regenerate
data in a log file copy and paste it do
all this entry we just changed one line
of code in our programs and our process
minimizes human error data entries
tedious people don't like doing it and
it's prone to errors and finally we have
get and get neatly trucks our workflow
and manages our file structures so we're
doing really well here okay so just
gonna give a brief overview about how it
works so we use a couple really great
packages tidy verse markdown we use
cable extra to do some rendering of
latex tables we've used a package called
question R which is a nice package for
working with survey data and then just a
bunch of other kind of great classic
packages so how it works is we go
through a survey vendor and they give us
a nice pretty pretty clean dataset we do
some of our own basic data basic
cleaning on the data and that's kind of
just to generate our own variables that
we use a lot so we ask a question about
what income where you fall on the income
distribution as I showed you earlier we
might want to do something like group
people into high income middle income
low income instead of using just these
those preset intervals so we write
custom functions that are going to take
in some basic information
such as what variables we're looking at
the chart type we want to produce so
maybe we want to do just a basic bar
chart maybe we want to do group bar
chart something like that and then just
some parameters like titles things like
that and then we use that to produce the
figures so for each chapter
we can create an R markdown file that
just produces a PDF of all the tables
and charts in that chapter and it's also
going to produce that excel file which
we have to send over to our editing
department ok and now I'm gonna just
walk through a quick example of what
that actually looks like in practice and
what some of the code looks like so I'm
going to use some tables and charts from
the income chapter and I'll show just
some code for some different functions
so I'm going to just start with this
really basic type graph so this is just
bar chart family income distribution
pretty simple ok so this is what our
question looks like this is one of those
multiple-choice questions where you can
only select one of these so we ask you
which of the following categories best
describes the total income that you and
your partner receive from all sources
etc so you pick one of those and that
will come up in our data kind of the way
I showed you earlier and this is where
we've we've written some of our own
programs so we have two programs here
and the first is a read data program
this is going to read in a clean data
set as I mentioned so it will do all the
internal cleaning that we want to have
and then it will define some paths that
we that everyone's going to use so it's
gonna make sure that people are using
the same data set so you're not gonna
load in this file and you're not going
to make any edits on that data set it's
gonna be the exact same data set and
you're gonna be using the same paths so
it's gonna go to where output needs to
go and yeah no flexibility there and
then finally we just source our basic
functions file that we wrote that has
some custom made functions to do this so
I want to just show like what we're
doing here and this is from the question
our package that I showed you earlier
the presentations earlier this morning
have given me a lot of ideas for
improving this
so we're just using this weighted table
function we give it the variable the
weights and then we can pipe it into
table and data frame and we just get
this frequency distribution pretty
simple and that's what we want to show
integral okay so what we do next is we
just specify where it's gonna be written
to so for each chapter we're just gonna
have like income if we're writing for
the income chapter it's gonna be an
income excel file open a workbook and
then we have this next step which is one
of the custom functions that we wrote so
we're gonna prep this data to go into
the visual we showed so the function we
have for this is called prep 1 vert
multi-cat so it's just for when you have
one variable that has multiple
categories so but this is what the
function looks like below so it takes in
a data frame and I should specify that
this data input is gonna be what's
loaded into your environment when you
source this read data function every
data file yeah so then we have so in the
function up there the crap 1 bar or
input is the data input and then the
variable we're looking at and down here
we can see that it's just using this
other function we wrote called shed
table which produces the kind of output
we want for our report and I'll show
that on the next slide and it just does
some basic formatting of stuff to kind
of make it look nice for what we want so
yeah this is what it looks like so we
just wanted kind of one function that
people can put some variable names into
you and just get like a basic tabulation
out for what our format is going to look
like so it takes in a data frame either
one or two variables depending on if it
has two variables it'll do a crosstab or
not and then our data actually comes
clean with labels so we'll use the
attributes and labels to add labels to
that and then we will just return this
and finally we have a do all function
that we wrote
combines all of these different steps in
the process as you can see it's not as
nice and pretty yeah as it is in the
final chapter but this is good enough
for editing they get the idea and we
send that off to them and so I should so
in here we specify a chart type so this
is just one bar chart and then we have
just a function there that looks like
this and that's just gonna have some
basic ggplot making a pretty simple
graph yeah and then some other
specifications for that so we had the
format of our data in particular can
make it a little bit challenging to
easily produce tables in charts for this
report unfortunately and we can use our
two kind of account for that and
automate a lot of the production
processes for annual survey it still
needs a little bit of work we produce
this kind of on the fly last year I
produced this mostly with the help of a
PhD statistician that we had on detail
in our section last year who was amazing
and it still needs some work
but it's really really improves our
process and eventually the goal is to
make this into a package that will be
able to be used by the public so people
can pull our data work with it reproduce
what we have see how we did things all
that and I want to just kind of I guess
flag what what a lot of people have been
emphasizing here before before I
presented it especially my colleague my
colleague BJ about communicating you
really need to be able to my boss is a
PhD economist she's been at the Fed for
almost 15 years she's use data really be
able to communicate kind of the points
where Stata is not working as well and
maybe we can use something else to kind
of fix those bottlenecks yeah so if you
want to learn more about shed this is
where we have all our information if you
want to learn more about me you can find
my personal website my github account
and on Twitter if you have any questions
feedback suggestions or if you just want
to email me and brainstorm some ideas
about automating your job too feel free
to email me right there and that's it
thank you
[Applause]